they're out to get you know the best
drama iconic reality TV moments we can't
get enough of I want to forgive you and
I want to forget you but what are these
stars up to today ET investigates the
first ever Bachelorette Trista Sutter
weds her hubby Ryan in 2003 today
they're living with their two kids in
Colorado they want in the end the true
love story Brooke Hogan first showed us
her singing skills on the vh1 reality
show Hogan knows best
[Music]
today she's still making music but now
she's a country artist I have lived in
Nashville for four years and a lot of
people don't know that because I wanted
to get away and forget the reality TV
thing for a while forget the same thing
the hills wrapped up its six season run
in 2010 Lauren Conrad and Kristin
Cavallari are now both moms and crushing
it as fashion designers and lifestyle
experts
Spencer Pratt and Heidi Montag are also
new parents but they'll never abandon
their reality roots we do a reality show
every year since we have ended reality
on the hill self yeah we are
professional reality stars
remember this hopeless romantic Oh G the
original H bi-phase New York
aka Tiffany Pollard is now 35 and still
doing plenty of reality TV including
Celebrity Big Brother where she still
her same unfiltered self what is your
favorite memory looking back with Flavor
Flav
listen let me tell you something that
minions under his Jean
[Music]
now goes down the same kaho mama June
has made some drastic changes since
starring on here comes honey boo boos
for one she's no longer with sugar bear
and she's dropped over three hundred
pounds after undergoing gastric sleeve
surgery I wouldn't have the gastric
sleeve done and then I wouldn't had my
sty making my things done last week my
breasts done and then I had my arms my
chin done and so it kind of makes me
feel like you know y'all are see me what
I've always see myself as also in the
TLC family Jon Gosselin who rose to fame
in 2007 when he and now ex-wife Kate
Gosselin starred in Jon & Kate Plus
eight might be a crazy life but it's our
life the couple split in 2009 but John
says he wouldn't do anything differently
the experiences I've had on television
are astronomical the people I've met the
things I do now I would have changed a
little bit
maybe contractual a wise but I don't
have any regrets
my kids are financially taken care of
and I can't go back you know I just
couldn't learn the 2000s also gave us an
intimate look at several of our favorite
musicians personal lives like Britney
Spears who starred in a short-lived uh Q
series with then-husband Kevin Federline
called Britney and Kevin chaotic
[Music]
the couple split in 2006 after two years
of marriage kevin has since appeared in
other reality shows mostly centered
around weight loss you know do your
thing
[Music]
you